and here we go
first of all gentlemen thanks for being
here Jeremy thanks for coming back again
thanks Jeff and thanks to you sir it's
very excited to be here very exciting
for me to be here to be able to talk to
you about your story
thank you I'm glad to be here David tell
everybody who you are and tell everybody
your background please okay and my name
is David forever
I served 24 years in the military
enlisted marine for a couple years
they sent me to Naval Academy then I
flew for 18 years for the Navy had
literally flew a-sixes Hornets and then
super hornets had every qualification
you could get in the airplane everything
even the stuff they're not doing anymore
so I had nvg high/low went to Top Gun
and at the time of the incident we're
going to talk about I was a commanding
officer of VF a41 the black aces
um I've gone through a gurney with this
whole UFO stuff from being a full-on
true believer to being incredibly
skeptical to trying to be open-minded to
being more of a believer now than I
think I've ever been before
and one of the things that I've always
said is the people that I believe that
there's a lot of loony people out there
but the people that I put my trust in
are high-level military people like
yourself so when I hear someone like you
who has a story that defies logic or
defies conventional understanding of how
aircrafts work that's when that's when I
sit back and I go okay this this is a
different thing because you know there's
always people that are telling you
they're psychic or they can you know
they sense things or they're in
communication with Bigfoot there's
always loony people out there but when
someone is in the military someone who's
trained to fly these in Krabi how
expensive for those jets when we haven't
met about seventy million dollars a
piece yeah they don't give those two
morons typically not some people in my
family would probably argue that point
but a better lucky than good it just
seems to me that this is for rational
people that want to look at this whole
UFO
objectively you're the type of person
that I want to talk to so I was very
excited to have you in here so what year
was your incident and you have a very
very famous incident that's krob
corroborated by actual evidence which is
one of the rare ones what year was it
and where did it take place
so as 2004 November 14th of the it's
really if you draw San Diego to Ensenada
Mexico or about 60 miles off the coast
in between the two we're doing work ups
so when we get ready to deploy this was
for the 2005 deployment we were going at
sea for November and December of 2004 so
we had been out I'd just taken over the
squadron mid-october so I'd been the CEO
for a month so we go out and we're
putting the Battle Group pieces together
so it's not just the the Air Wing but we
were you know we're on the carrier we've
got the cruiser we've got all support
ships out there and we're gonna
integrate all the defenses and train as
one unit so the exercise we're going to
do is an air defense exercise where
there's good guys bad guys they're all
from internal from the Air Wing so two
bad guys today are gonna be the Marines
VM fat32 the Red Devils so they're gonna
launch and they're gonna go about
hundred miles south of the ship and
we're the good guys and it's we called a
2v2 so it's two of us against two of
them we're going to work with the USS
Princeton which is going to be the
controller and they're going to control
the blue forces and then the red guys
are going to give us a presentation that
you know they're going to try and
intercept so we can stop them from
getting up towards the carrier so that's
kind of the training set that we're all
good so the Marines take off first and
they start heading to the South now we
have no idea that for two weeks this is
the two weeks we've been at sea they've
been tracking these things coming out of
the sky and when I talked to the Prince
controller he's like up to about a dozen
of them they would come down from above
80,000 feet they drop down to about
20,000 feet and hang out and then it
goes straight back up after about three
or four hours so when you say they've
been tracking them who specifically this
is the USS the Princeton is tracking
them they saw him on the Nimitz radar
and the e2 could see them so because
they're out there you know that radar is
on all the time
and the spy-1 system on an Aegis Cruiser
is you know the state of ours probably
was one of the most sophisticated
systems in the world so typically when
something like this happens and
some unexplained phenomenon what do they
do in this case that you know if it was
if we were in a threat environment they
would tell us but they're off the coast
of San Diego it doesn't come to the air
wing so we have no idea that these
things are out there at all so they
observe these things and they never
bother telling any of you guys that's
correct so they just knew that these
things had been visiting this area but
they just allowed this training exercise
to take place anyway
yeah talking to him the previous for the
two weeks they would show up but it was
when we weren't flying
so the typical carrier schedule is you
know for us it was about noon to
midnight it's a 12-hour day there's
reasons for that you can go a lot longer
they can but for training we just do the
12-hour day thing and it's cyclic ops so
you got guys taking off and landing
periodically so we were on one of the
first goes you know it's you know noon
one o'clock somewhere on there and we
take off the Marines take off first and
my buddy cheeks who's the CEO of the
marine squadron was one he was leading
the red air they had when he launched
off the carrier first they called him up
and said hey what do you got on board
well the the small the original legacy
f-18s don't have as much gas as the
super hornets super hornets about thirty
percent bigger so they start talking to
him about fuel and based on how long
we're gonna be airborne and everything
else they go hey why don't you just go
ahead and proceed to your your cap point
and because we had just taken off and
that's when the controller had come up
and said hey yeah I forget our cost and
spread like dealers usually what we went
so it'd be like dealer one one this is
Princeton control what do you got you
know say your loadout kind of chuckled
he said I said I got a Kadim nine which
is a it's a basically of just a blue
metal tube with a seeker head for a name
9ir missile it's a training it doesn't
come off the airplane you can beat it
with a sledgehammer that's the only way
you're gonna get it off or you got to
unlock the lugs with a key so I'm like
kind of chuckling because well hey we're
gonna cancel the training so we're like
okay he says we got real-world vector
and they're gonna send us out to the
west so picture if it's you know if you
got a clock the Nimitz is in the middle
we're a little bit south of that about
forty miles south and then the Marines
are about a hundred miles south of the
ship about sixty miles between the two
of us so as this is all happened in my
wingman is joining up all right and
these are f-18s so there's two people in
each jet so it's me and my WIZO which is
weapon systems operator and i've got
the other pilot and the weapon systems
operator any other jet so they tell us
all this hey we're gonna real world
vector and they send us out to seven
zero about sixty miles away from where
we're going so now we're going out even
further out to sea we have no idea what
we're intercepting and this is when the
controller starts talking to us he says
hey sir we've seen these objects they've
been for two weeks they've been coming
down and he's given us the whole story
says we need you to go investigate we
want to know what these are but they're
asking you to investigate in a jet
that's unarmed that's correct okay yeah
we have no there's reasons for that that
we don't fly we typically don't fly with
live ordnance unless we're actually
going into like a combat zone or we're
on a training range and we're gonna
shoot something and the reason is you
can go through history of the Navy or
Air Force if you put live missiles on
airplanes and then you start doing
training where you're squeezing the
trigger someone always messes the switch
ology up and someone gets shot down it's
happened multiple times so we don't do
it you know there's times that we do but
it's rare so we start flying out to the
west now I want you to think because the
other pilot has a you know when you talk
to it's good south it was a female when
you talk to her it's she hears the kind
of goes through the mindset of hey we're
off the coast of Mexico real world
vector we have no idea we're going to
look at probably drug runner cuz you get
the drum runners coming up the coast so
we're like okay so we drive out and
they're calling down ranges so they're
telling us hey it's two-seven-zero at 30
miles at 20,000 feet and then it's you
know you just count down the ranges and
we're talking back and forth the whole
time so they got to a point where they
say hey merge plot which means radars
have resolution cells
you know range and asmath of what the
radar can actually see once you're
inside that box you can't tell the
difference between me and the object I'm
going in will just become one big blob
mmm so they call merge plot and so the
other jet is on my left-hand side and
we're gonna and I'm going to go to a
clock code to make it simple so the
object we're going to end up looking for
is then right in the middle of the clock
and we are at the six o'clock position
and my wingman is off to my left side so
it's she's further down with her widow
so as we're looking around we we look to
the right and there's a it was yesterday
there's a perfect
example out here that water is perfectly
calm no Whitecaps I mean it's literally
a perfect San Diego California day and
we see white water it's something like
if you see a seamount you know rock
underwater when you're standing on the
shore and the waves are breaking over
and you're like what is that it's
usually because there's a rock under the
water so it looks like that but it's
about the size of a 737 it actually kind
of has a shape of like a cross and it's
pointing to the east so you've got the
long part going east-west and you got a
couple of things going north and south
so as we're looking at it cuz that kind
of draws our eyes we're like oh that's
kind of odd we look down and whiz oh and
the other airplane comes up and says hey
skipper do you and that's about what he
gets out of his mouth and I'm kind of
looking at the same thing I go dude you
see that what is that thing and what we
see is this white tic-tac looking object
just above the surface of the water
pointing north-south and it's going
north south east west it's just
radically moving forward back left right
at will and it's moving around the
disturbance the white water that we see
how big is this thing over time it's
about 40 feet long and the way I asked
to mate that is I mean I got a lot of
time fighting other airplanes so it's
about lot size of a Hornet fuselage so
that's why you say forty feet this
thing's just going left so the first
thing you see when you look down you go
and this is with our eyes it's not
sensors right so we're looking down at
this thing and first thing you think is
helicopter right there are the
helicopters typically stay below 200
feet when we're out there and they're
just driving around we're pretty far
away from the ship for a helicopter for
one of ours so what is it so the first
thing you look for is rotor wash you
know if you've watched any TV show that
starts kicking the water up and you can
see that it's really easy to see from
the air so we're like no rotor wash
matter of fact don't see any rotors
don't see any tail rotor don't see any
you know the main rotors or like that's
kind of weird so as we're driving around
we're looking at this thing we get to
about the nine o'clock position how far
away are you from this thing I'm at
20,000 feet and it's right down on the
surface - right off our right side so
I'm probably maybe a couple miles
lateral and 20,000 feet and we're just
watching it move around and so it's very
small in your eyes um not overly smarmy
and airplane down that low it's 40 feet
it was pretty clear so I'm like okay so
I said I'm gonna go check it out that's
what we're trained to do the other pilot
says hey I'm the
stay up here and I'm like that's perfect
so now we'll get some separation we'll
get it from different views and the
other airplane will act kind of a God's
eye view everything that's going on as I
go down and check this thing out
so I start driving around and it's still
doing its Ford back left right it's
still pointing north south we get to
about the 12 o'clock position I'm just
in a nice easy descent a reason you know
because I've been asked how can you go
more aggressive you can but when you're
out over water the water looks the same
at 20,000 feet it does it 2,000 feet you
don't you know yeah so you can easily
put yourself in a non recoverable
position if you're not paying attention
and you go into the water so I got this
nice you just send I get to about 12
o'clock and as I'm coming down you know
I could guess probably about you know
18,000 feet now a couple thousand feet
below the other airplane the tic-tac
just kind of rapidly goes and turns so
now it's kind of point east-west and now
it mirrors us so it's above the surface
or up high we're coming down it starts
coming up well this is getting
interesting
so we kind of drive all the way around a
circle I'm descending it's coming up and
I get over to about the eight o'clock
position of the on a clock and it's over
at about the two o'clock position
well the quickest way as we know as kids
to get someone you know you can keep
going around the circle nothing's going
to happen you cut across the circle some
about I don't know pry two to three
thousand feet above it and I just kind
of drop my nose aggressively and I cut
across the circle and it's coming this
way because I'm trying to fly to where
it's gonna be because I want to join on
it I want to see how close I can get to
right and as I'm pulling up it's kind of
starting to cross my nose and it starts
to accelerate and within about less than
a second as I start to pull nose onto it
and it crosses right in front of me it
just goes poof and it's gone so I call
the other airplane I said hey you guys
you guys see that thing and they're like
sure it's gone we don't see it at all so
I'm like okay that's kind of weird so we
don't see it we're looking at the same
time I say hey let's turn around and
let's go back to see what was in the
water you know there's was there
something there so we turn around right
there we haven't gone anywhere it's gone
waters perfectly there's no white water
nothing it's just blue like okay so we
turned back around now we're heading
back out towards the east and I tell the
controller I said well I said you know
first said I'm kind of weirded out and I
told my my backseater that we start
heading back and the controller on the
Princeton comes at me says sir you're
not going to believe this but that thing
is back at your cat point that was our
original point where we were gonna hold
40 miles south of the ship so this thing
is went from wherever we were at - it's
kind of about 60 miles in you know maybe
30 40 seconds it's already over there
and it just and they didn't track it it
just appeared he just shows back up on
their radar and they go it's here so
we're like okay so we fly back we don't
see it we don't see it on our radar we
don't see it on any of our sensors we do
like two runs and we come back to the
ship and land so as we're in our it's we
call it the PR shop we're taking off our
flight gear one of my crews is getting
ready to go out and I think they were
going to be on a tanker mission but they
had a targeting pod on board so they
launched off and we're tell him about
this before and I in the back seat er
Chad says he's really determined he's
gonna find this thing so he tells the
pilot hey we're gonna find this thing so
turns out driving around and in the back
seat of a Super Hornet
there's no stick but there's side stick
controllers and they're to control the
sensors because that's what the weapons
systems guys do and they can change
displays really fast by just hitting a
button and will flip from the radar to
the targeting pod and the way the system
actually works is when you see something
on the radar and you designate it as
your primary target all the other
sensors will look at that point so it's
everything's kind of synced together so
he picks up a hit on his radar and he
goes to lock it up because I watched all
the tapes he goes to lock it up and
immediately the radar can tell it gets
signals back that it's being jammed so
and technically jamming is an act of war
it starts jamming the radar goes into a
jam extrapolate a bunch of stuff happens
on the scope well he's smart enough to
castle to his targeting pod and he takes
a passive track and that's the video
that you see of the tic-tac where it's
just sitting in the middle screen real
quiet so he does that and he and he goes
through if you watch the video if we had
and I'd go through it with you but they
go through all the different modes so he
goes it's an IR and an EO EO as TV it's
black and white TV camera we do we can
get the video right online yes let's get
the video Jimmy where would you
can't show it to anybody we can't we
can't show it on YouTube but you can see
it and people will be able to go to it
you know what we'll do
go to the video and we'll tell people
when we're starting and we'll tell
people with the title of the video that
you get to is and they can sync it up
themselves if they're watching it it's
publicly owned it's you know American
government right so it is actually
something in the public domain so you
think we could play it on YouTube and
not get cold yeah a hundred percent you
think so Jamie it's a government those
things I would say yes we should be able
to but sometimes those things get messy
so let's take a genius okay let's take a
chance with this one I know if you go if
you're on a New York Times article
there's a link to it it's had it gone
really YouTube is crazy with copyright
stuff and we've always been like two
steps away from getting pulled off
YouTube completely it's a real disaster
it's understand from their perspective
there's a lot of legal issues they have
to deal with but I have it on a private
server I could maybe send Jamie the
issue I'd believe though is the actual
copyright of the video itself oh it's
just it's um Pentagon Pentagon released
Public Enemy and the Pentagon's can come
after us I don't think so either you
find it I want to find a good version of
the video that doesn't have somebody
Jeremy I'm watermark version please look
it up the sons of Jeremy over to us
I have to figure out how to send it to
you right here give me in a second do
you have air drop what did you hear drop
yeah but I got it on a bit pay I got it
on a page a private page they can send
Jamie oh yeah okay okay Jeff Jamie's uh
info no okay I'll figure it out Lee says
to me and I'll send to him okay that's
pretty easy sorry to disrupt the
momentum no but I think this it's
probably important to be able to have
this the the video itself so you could
just talk about it and we're about to
yank it up here okay Jamie wrote it down
for you there you go give me a second to
get it okay and for people don't know
Jeremy also produced bob lazar area 51
in flying saucers and he was in here
when we had bob lazar in talked about
Bob's experience
and Jesus if that wasn't a game-changer
for me and for a lot of other people
this is a subject that it's so easy to
mock you know this is why I think it's
so important that we talk to people like
you because like I said just your
average everyday UFO crackpot they
believe everything in anything have you
did you have you ever had any UFO
experiences before this know the irony
and I tell this story my mother in law
shall be listening she she literally
every time I would go home she would ask
me hey did you see UFO do you see if you
haven't I'd be like no when I first
started dating my wife she was a big
like National Enquirer she had all the
you know supermarket tabloids and I
would always just feed her crap for it
so I this happens and you know and I'm I
never say a word so my friends all knew
it was a great story over beers cuz they
go hey what's the coolest thing you ever
saw flying I go I chased a UFO and they
go seriously and I tell them the store
and they're like dude I go yeah so I go
home and and I got got asked by Lou
Elizondo to do the New York Times
article which as like anything else I
always say no like it took a bunch of
times to get me on your show Jeremy kept
asking asking asking and it was Thank
You Jeremy Mike yeah yeah I thank my
contractor's wife angel who we were to
party drinking and she goes we got to do
Rogan I go what she goes
it's the biggest podcast on the planet
she goes you got to do it and I go
alright I'm gonna do it just for you I
want to do this show a shout-out to
angel yeah from New Hampshire so so my
mother-in-law we're sitting there and I
know the New York Times article is gonna
come out and as I was at Thanksgiving in
20 when there were a come on seventeen
so it's Thanksgiving in 2017 I never
wanted to kind of left the house that's
just my wife and my in-laws a couple I
was sitting in the kitchen and I said
hey I got to tell you guys this they
said what I said there's gonna be this
article comes out in the New York Times
and I'm in it and they're like yeah go
well I chased a UFO my mother-in-law is
like haha she looks at my father-in-law
he's rolling his eyes looking at me like
are you serious and I go yeah yeah and
and she's like you never told us I got
never really told anyone I mean my wife
and kids knew the event happened but
they didn't have all the details cuz
there's just one of those things we just
didn't I just didn't get into is it
classified
no was it at any point in time no
a lot of rumors out there that I was
classified and the ship got locked down
no it wasn't it was we were never men in
suits did not show up no one told us not
to talk about it and this is because
there's a lot of other people saying
other things and I said this look at it
that here's the context so in the battle
group you've got the Admiral
you got the captain of the ship the
captain of the Princeton and then you've
got the other COS so in position wise
I'm probably as a CEO of a squadron in
the top 20 out of 6,000 and no one came
to talk to me no one came to take my
tapes no one showed up in a suit no one
told me not to talk no one talked to any
of my aircrew that were involved in this
all there's six people total involved
the two they shot the video on the four
of us that looked at it for five minutes
with our eyes knowing nothing it just
and I can get into how that you know
there's a report that that George Knapp
got released it's a I call it the
unofficial official report and I had met
someone and I'm like hey can you find
any I had this incident normally you
tell people this they look at you like
dude what are you smoking I'm like no no
I'm good I'm tested and they go and and
they said well let me see what I can do
and I had got a call I was working I was
doing some aerospace work and I had
gotten a call my cell phone from a guy
and he said hey I want to investigate
your incident and I go okay so he did he
investigated the incident and it was
very very thorough I mean if you've read
that it's about 10 pages long and he
yeah I mean he tracked down everybody he
tracked down all the people that were
the aircrew that were involved he talked
to he tracked down the Admiral he talked
you mean he it was a pretty thorough
report and I don't think anything of it
you know because you know the the people
who weren't it's out there so they want
to do FOIA but it was never released in
a FOIA request I actually had the Navy
call me I'd been out of the Navy for
like six years and what's explain to
people that means freedom moved
infrequently so I got called by a public
affairs person from the Navy and said
hey is this commander forever I said
yeah they said hey do you know of any
documentation on your UFO incident off
the Nimitz
and I said official and she said yeah I
said no because I knew the rapport
existed but to me it was an unofficial
because I didn't know who were when I
and I had a copy of it but because it
wasn't official well then years later I
find out that the guy who actually did
the report was part of the a tip team
and I was talking to Lou Elizondo who
runs that program and Lou showed me the
documentation of the original I think is
like 13 people that were part of a tip
and they were fully exempt and I'm like
well that's kind of well hey I know that
guy he's a guy that did the report which
is why it never ever came out no George
got his hands on how does something
Freedom of Information Act exempt
obviously DoD has the ability because
I'm a I'm not a conspiracy theory person
at all I mean I'll just tell you that
you know I think there's reasons that
the government doesn't tell the public
everything and I don't speak for the
government but I think there's a good
reason for that that not everything
needs to go out to the public but most
of it does and they just what they do is
I put a clause on hey for this program
or whatever we're doing which would been
an a-type program the work that they do
and what they find is not it's not
releasable through Freedom of
Information Act there's probably other
avenues to get that you know and then
you go well what really is freedom
information because I got into this
sauna I was talking to someone who's a
conspiracy theorist and they said well
so and so wrote and they're not getting
any information on your event I said so
what are they gonna do they're gonna
call up you're gonna put in your request
for for freedom information you go
here's what I want it goes to some poor
guy at the Pentagon who's like I have no
idea what this is and he searches around
he doesn't find anything he looks at his
bud and I gain all for you I go hey Joe
you got anything on the Nimitz incident
you go oh I go okay well I didn't find
anything I looked I did my due diligence
but I'm not gonna spend the next six
months of my life doing your research
project for you right so you get nothing
and then you assume the government's
covering up when they go that really
isn't they just you know the guys are
doing the research doesn't know where
it's had or nice access to it makes
sense um Jamie we have the video okay
here we go
now explain what what is what are we
seeing why we seeing it in this this
particular cat the don't
on the top left corner na R is narrow
field of view which is zoomed in IR at
the top middle it means it's an infrared
mode so instead of seeing color you're
seeing temperature variations
and these things are extremely sensitive
to in like tents of degrees they will
tell you the difference so it'll go from
black to white so in this case white is
hot so if you look down on the bottom
left corner it says WH T mm that's white
it means white is hot so the object that
you're looking at is hotter than the sky
around it but we also notice is there's
no plumes not if you're looking at an
airplane when you get closer you'll
actually see the exhaust coming out and
there will be a really glowing plume
that's important as we look at the video
and then most of the stuff on here you
really don't need to know what you can
look at is the bottom right corner it
says $19,990 tude and if you look up in
the little words or it says HD G and
then B alt B it's autopilot so it's on
altitude hold it's just flying for that
so you can go ahead and play the video
and so those two bars next to the white
object that's a that's a that's a
passive track so what he's done is he's
commanded the FLIR to track that so what
the system does is it uses its actually
tracking it can track pixels and it's
just basically blocked those hot pixels
those white pixels from the black ones
and you're gonna see now pause it real
quick so it over the top see it went to
a white screen with the black object
this is a black and white TV mode and
even look at the top says TV so narrow
in TV mode is actually you can get
closer than narrow and IR it's literally
narrow in IR is about medium and TV mode
so there's you can get closer with the
TV mode so as you look at it now in this
case you would actually start to see
stuff going on and even in TV mode
because you get exhaust you know the
black exhaust that comes out he'll
usually be able to see kind of some of
that coming out the back and you don't
see anything this thing's just sitting
there and if you look at the the top
where it says three right that's the pot
is looking three degrees right on the
nose of the airplane right so he's just
flying along the bottom numbers don't
worry those are time so it's 41 56 so go
ahead and hit play and what what he's
doing is he's going Chad's going through
all the different modes cuz he's like oh
I got it and he's gonna try and see the
best video you can get now there's
rumors that this video is like 10
minutes long know what you're looking at
is the entire video now notice where it
says 99.9 mm-hmm so hit pause real quick
what that means is the why he's got the
pod the targeting pod because that's his
primary sensor right now the radar still
trying to look at this object
and trying to range it and the radar
can't get ranging on it so the object is
doing something to say I'm not giving
you back because it's just a Doppler
radar just like a police radar as a
Doppler it's trying to get arranging on
you and it can't do it so when it says
99.9 the radar cannot see this object
right now mmm it's not allowing it to
get ranging and I think that's super
important Dave the way he explained it
to me
active jamming compared to passive
jamming this is a technology that is
actively jamming this system rather than
something like stealth aircraft which is
the shape and texture of the yeah it's
because I one thinks stealth is
invisible it's not it's it's just it's a
technology to to basically make it
harder for radars to see you you know
and that's the whole thing you know if
you look at you know airplanes that are
knows on are harder to see than
airplanes at the sides kind of like
think of a barn door if you're looking
at the whole barn door it's really easy
see if I turn the barn door sideways
works really thin it's gonna be a lot
harder for you to see it guys so that's
it that's the easiest most basic way to
look at this so keep going you can play
again
and you can look to the airplane is
still sitting at 20,000 feet it's doing
250 knots he's gonna go through
different modes and try and lock it and
it's just kind of sitting in all of a
sudden as the video goes on I think it's
a minute and a half long see it's going
to try and reacquire it Rhys enters the
pod so it's it's slowly drifting to the
left the the Hornet is still going the
same heading it's just kind of hanging
out and they're just filming this thing
and I when they get close it's gonna
zing off the left-hand side when you see
it on a full because it's you know you
think digital you'd be able to get a
one-for-one copy I'm like you know when
you copy your album to a cassette you
know you lose a little quality well you
still do in digital world and they're
off it goes to the left and that's
pretty fast to leave that field of view
on the when we have big monitors that we
look at these when they come back so
we're looking at the original tapes so
they the end of that again please Jamie
so when it's taking off how fat when
when it just sort of like leaves the
field of view and takes off to the left
how fast is that going I would say
pretty fast it's an estimate if we had
ranging you know you could obviously
view the triangle and go hey because we
know how big the field of view is but
for something to leave the field of view
that fast with the pod just staring is
pretty fast I mean it just it's like out
of here like nothing that
we have no because we can't I don't care
what airplane is so let's just use the
f-22 Raptor that's probably one of the
it's probably the best airplane in the
world right now performance wise it
can't take off like that especially if
it's a hover I mean you're talking
something that's just sitting in space
in the wind and then it just all of a
sudden accelerates airplanes don't work
that way and it's not leaving any
exhaust plume no notice there's none and
when you go back to geography n even in
the IR you don't yes here's IR zoomed in
and there's no you would see a plume if
that was an airplane
it's creepy how it takes off yeah with
active jamming it's intelligently
controlled there's no rotors there's no
plumes there's no exhaust there's no
tail fin there's no tail number this
thing goes from a standstill takes off
it's a propulsion system we don't have
in our inventory and no other nation
does that's how it's understood by the
government now that that's say if the
fastest plane on earth was trying to do
that same maneuver this system would be
able to track it yeah well yeah we'd
stay with it
until it got to the limits of the pod
you know as far as looking to the left
but right and you know the radar would
see it I mean we get get close enough
you're gonna you know everything becomes
visible because you get burned through
with radar and how how radars actually
work this one is you know you tell me
but this was performance beyond I mean
it's like when we saw it disappear when
it flew in front of my nose I'm talking
something I'm within a half mile of it
looking at it and it gets in front of me
and just disappears
so take we'll just go to something that
everyone knows as fast let's just say
sr-71 that's doing Mach 3
you know the visibilities fifty miles so
even at 35 miles a minute I'm gonna be
able to see this thing turn into a
little dot as it goes off into the
horizon for a probably a minute the
thing that we saw disappeared in a
second just gone and that's from two
different angles remember the other
airplanes 8,000 feet above me because we
we get close to at about 12,000 feet so
the other airplanes above me looking
down and when it disappeared I said you
guys see it they said no it's gone they
just literally was poof
now when you came back and what do you
do with this information do you report
it do you talk to people about it
so the typical process any time we fly
everything gets debrie so because it was
a two-seat airplane usually the junior
person then the jet goes down so I was
the boss so I wasn't going down there so
we have a thing called Civic c VI C
which is the carrier Intel Center so
they go down we always take our tapes
because we record stuff when we're
fighting they take it down and it's
really to exercise the system when we're
in training so that when we actually get
over to in this case we are going over
to the Persian Gulf you know anything
that we do comes in and gets debriefing
then it all gets sent off that's how you
get the CNN video and all that so they
go down and a debrief and I have to tell
hey we we chase this object we don't
know what it is you know and of course
everyone now is gonna make jokes because
we know we're gonna catch [ __ ] because
that's how the Navy works you know and I
told him I said I remember telling the
guy in my back seat I said dude you know
we're gonna catch maximum [ __ ] for this
and he goes yes sir I'll show you the
comics I have him on my phone we do the
airplane comes out so we know it's gonna
come down so he goes any day debrief
this both crews going in and of course
everyone at Intel thinks this is
hilarious so the flight the you know
Chad comes in with his tapes you know
and when he lands and there's the thing
yeah vfa 41 ha ha guys see any UFOs out
there and he pulls out that tape and
drops it on the counter he goes yeah
it's on here so they're like oh [ __ ] so
they copy it they play it and there's a
big it looks like a rack system they put
the eight mil in it gets copied to a
hard drive and then they they archive it
so you go okay so I got this video and
then you know the ship spreads you know
if you have a room around the ship 5,000
people are gonna know about it within
probably thirty minutes I mean it
spreads that it's like a virus so the
whole ship now knows that we chased this
I guarantee the whole Princeton knew
this stuff was going on and it goes all
the way up the Admiral knows about it
the captain of the ship knew about it
and and then all the movies because we
have they play movies for us on the ship
and they run like a 12 hour loops of
course the movie selection is men and
black men and black
two signs Independence Day and and we
know we're gonna be on the airplane
comet because there's always a comic so
you do some stupid or like this then
you're gonna be on the comm I'll show
you the comics here a little bit oh
they're pretty funny but you know so
that went on for two days but you know
we're in the middle of work ups
I got a squadron to run so it's like you
know there was after about the first day
and a half early died down and then it
was there's always that closet people
that you don't think that it really like
UFO buffs and you know like we had one
on one like one of the Marines would
always come and eat sit down hey hey
skipper can I sit with you okay you want
to talk about the UFO he goes yeah I
just I can't get it out of my mind and
then we would just sit there and talk
about it you know and to me it was like
you know we're just saying you know my
entire now flying career is defined by
five minutes of chasing this white
tic-tac vice almost 4,000 hours you know
flying so now did you encounter anyone
else that had a similar experience I've
talked to the guys a couple of guys from
the East Coast event the gimbal video
mm-hmm
one of them I talked to you daily he's
pretty good friend of mine totally
different now keep in mind ours is 2004
the gimbal video is 2015
the funny part about the gimbal video
and the East Coast stuff that was going
on because that's off the vacate so off
the coast of the United States sir
they're called warning areas and all
they are is their if you look out of
aviation map they're these big areas
that are blocked off by blue and they
say like whiskey 291 or whiskey 243 and
is the gimbal video available in the
same way that that video is available
yes yeah okay so and I was talking to
him about it cuz I asked a buddy of mine
he was just retired he was the he led
two fighter wing on the East Coast night
called him up because we start finding
out that these things were so prevalent
out off the east coast the United States
and there's a couple of them so there's
the we're going to talk what they
started seeing originally was these
things and one of them almost hit the
airplane almost hit one of these things
but it looks like a cube inside of a
clear beach ball so they don't know if
it's actually like a surrounding or it's
you don't know if it's a force field and
you see kind of in the gimbal via video
it's got like an aura around it where
ours didn't I always laugh I go ours was
tic-tac these are not that means there's
different stuff out there that we don't
know but they had two airplanes flying
and we fly when we go out to to Train
we're usually we have a distance you
know we'll just say we're you know ma
mile apart as we're flying out so
they're flying out and they're you know
the airplanes are deployed we caught
combat spread and one of the airplanes
almost hits one these goes close down
like 50 feet down the side and almost
hits one of these floating cubes inside
of the beach ball and if someone goes
out like it's a it's a balloon it's not
a balloon I mean these things are
literally sitting still they're there no
effect from the winds so if you got 90
knots of wind and they talk about it
these things are just sitting there so
60 or 70 people at see it because the
radars the the newer radar in the super
hornets is extremely extremely capable
okay and at first when they started
seeing stuff they were like that's just
like maybe it's the radar just give me a
false target and that really doesn't
give false targets and then someone did
exactly what Chad did is they threw
their targeting flare out there and all
of a sudden you see a heat signature
there's a return there's obviously
something out where that blip is at what
is a targeting flare that's a we caught
the 80 flares it's an advanced targeting
flirts it's on the left side of the
airplane and it's launched it like a
flare no no it's a it's a FLIR
forward-looking infrared receiver so
it's when you see the bombs blowing up
on TV and it's that looks like a black
and white and you see it's like that's
the targeting pod okay it's got a laser
in it it's got an IR marker in it it's
it's a very capable system that syncs up
to this to the Hornet so everything kind
of marries oh so this is the go-fast now
this is go fast no it's the other one
it's the was like that what is that
that's called the go fast that looks
like a tic-tac and I was another one
taking off the East Coast but they
grabbed it and Mark that one it's going
it's screaming across the ocean at a
very high rate of speed and there's been
some debunkers that say well it's really
not going that fast it's just the way
the airplane is and how the mechanics of
the Potter work and when you talk to the
crew cuz it's actually I could ask my
bud I'm pretty sure it's the same back
cedar took both of these videos took the
go-fast video and took the gimbal video
and my buddy was on the flight with the
gimbal video but they these things that
I call my buddies I'm like hey how many
people are seeing these things I got
like
60 or 70 60 or 60 or 70 people had seen
these things on radar and I said well
what do you do and they said well we put
out a note AM which is a notice to
Airmen that just says hey these things
are out there so just be careful because
we don't want you to hit one yeah and
it's kind of like our shego because you
would ask you know who do you tell well
everyone knows well what do you do and I
said well because it was all white and
it didn't have any markings on it and it
didn't have any wings and it didn't have
any rotors and it was just outperformed
anything that we have yeah I think if I
would have painted China or Russia on
the side is this the gimbal video yes
okay so it's the same pod in the
beginning Jamie what we're looking at
and when the crew finds it now what
you're not seeing you're seeing it
targeting when you hear them start
talking when you listen to the video
you'll hear the guy go dude look they're
all over look at the SA page so we have
a situation awareness page and whatever
the radar is getting returns on it'll
show up it's kind of like our God's eye
view in the airplane so the pod can only
look at one thing so he designates that
as his primary target so that's where
the pod is there the radar still seeing
everything else so what they're actually
seeing this video is what you're when
you see that the object that he's
tracking when I was talking to one of
the other pods he said there's actually
when you see the radar video there's
like a it almost looks like a formation
in front of them like five smaller ones
that are moving in front of it and then
they turn so like a formation these
things turns and starts going the other
way and then again while they're filming
the gimbal video and that's kind of the
comms when you hear it dude holy cow
look they're all over this is unreported
new information that he's actually
saying right now everybody knows this
video this is the one that they say
turns like the Lazar craft like
belly-first
however what he's telling you right now
is something that is not public yet he's
telling you that there was a V formation
of other objects that the public has yet
to see you're not going to you're not
going to the radar tape but I'm not
gonna there were more objects
surrounding this is what he's telling
you right now which is fascinating
because the world doesn't know that yet
just so you know I mean that's brand-new
that's never been reported by a New York
Times anybody okay
so you go ahead play
so the cool thing with this is that you
know when he goes into so he's an IR IR
mode right now you're still seeing no
plume he's looking 47 so they're
actually turning into it so it's
starting to pull it back towards the
nose see how the number at the top is
decreasing and it's against the wind now
he's in TV mode and this thing's gonna
just start to run you can kind of see
it's got that aura around it mm-hmm he
said they were saying that the the ones
with the squares inside that looked like
the beach ball were the same and this
thing is just hanging out so it's on the
airplanes on the left-hand turn and it's
so now it's right in front yeah it's
it's just rotating no this is how Lazare
described you know Lazar described that
that these things would lay flat and
then when they would travel they would
turn up on their side mhm and that's
that's how they maneuvered so this is
very similar eerily similar to the
propulsion system that Lazar talked
about and that's why this video we're
seeing it very differently now
especially with what we know about Lazar
but the idea is that it would fly
belly-first in high-speed mode so if
they have these are gravity propel this
is something that's known within the
government they're trying to back
engineer they're trying to understand it
we know there's a program currently that
they said is is gone however it is
currently active to study this these
things will turn belly first the saucer
type looking ones and then that's the
high speed mode because they focus of
allegedly you know these gravity wave
amplifiers look this thing turns
mechanically there again no typical form
of propulsion as an expert is telling
you this is not a glitch this is seen by
multiple radars multiple people
commander freighter was so close to it
this is something that is not
aerodynamic and it could move in ways
and fashions when he's underplaying it
when we first talked the idea of this
thing going up up up up up up it's
instantaneous acceleration back and
forth there's no slowing down no turning
like a ping-pong ball he said to me our
first talk ping-pong ball in a in a
glass nothing moves like that with
traditional reactionary propulsion
somebody has technology that we don't
have in our inventory at all
so this is counter-intuitive the way it
goes from being aerodynamic to being uh
narrow dynamic when it goes sideways and
flies belly forward that's correct it's
well it's not it's you know if you talk
because I was just talking that guy the
other day and he said the the irony with
is these things would be out there for
hours we don't have you know a
high-performance airplane does not have
hours where the gas I mean you know
Hornets we if we don't have area we're
feeling you know and we're actually out
doing a mission and fighting and going
fast you know you're talking hour and a
half and you're coming back to land some
airplanes are even less you know based
on their size you know so if like an
f-16 doesn't have external fuel tanks it
doesn't have a lot of gas and the Soviet
airplanes are the same way the mig-29
does not have a lot of gas the su-27
sweet 30s because of weight because it's
weight performance size of the airplane
so you know even even our
intercontinental bombers like b2 they
still take off and they error or fuel
they keep topped off so they can get to
range that's how we extend things you
got something like this that's coming
down you know just think of the physics
so just you know I'll use my instant
because that's the one I really know the
best is you've got an object coming from
above eighty thousand feet so I'll just
tell you that eighty thousand it's
somewhere around seventy eighty thousand
feet is where you can actually start to
see the curvature of the earth you know
so that's considered space so they're
coming from above that they're coming
straight down they stop at around twenty
thousand feet they hang out for three
hours and then they go straight back up
so and I know you had a lot on the show
so SpaceX is really excited because they
can launch a rocket and then they can
have the booster come back to earth and
actually land on a pad very impressive
engineering feat next to this technology
that's like a Model T next to a Porsche
I mean it's like wow really that's it
you know and you got something that can
just at will and move around now take it
to the next level and I know this is
there's a lot of talk about this so
think is going to go into speculation
mode but when you take a shape like that
so just take the tic-tac shape which is
shaped like a submarine if you're if
you're using a propulsion that's non
reactive where you're just manipulating
the median that you're in
err whatever you can go into the water
so when you hear the all the reports of
hey we've seen these things since you
know World War two that would come out
of the water and fly if you have a
technology like this as long as the
object is sealed where you're not going
to get water inside of it there's
nothing that says you can't do that
because all you're doing is you're not
you know where a jet engine sucks in air
and blows it out the back or a propeller
actually pushes the water it's a force
now you've got something that's actually
manipulating the gravity field and it's
just moving through a void then it
doesn't then air you could literally in
theory fly go into the ocean cruise
around pop back up fly around go to
space you're nothing you you remove the
barriers of the normal propulsion that
we have today there's been many
instances of sightings off the coast of
California of things that plunge into
the water or escape from the water and
take off into space
so yeah the with this field propulsion
system as commander favors describing as
Lazar described it doesn't matter the
medium of space air or water there's no
resistance no splash and this goes back
to you know when Christopher Columbus
reported a UFO sighting he did oh yeah
did this idea that so this has been
around anyway this idea boom that you
can go through these different mediums
will pause for a second Christopher
Columbus at a UFO sorry yeah it's it's a
written account so it's like find that
no video it's [ __ ]
Leslie but that's what's so cool so
commander framers encounter it's not the
most documented it's not the most
dramatic however it has had the most
impact out of any sighting because of
his credibility and the mere fact that
the the New York Times picked it up with
video footage radar evidence and
somebody who is as credible as commander
forever it has changed the dynamic of
the way people the government responds
new Navy protocols because of commander
flavor coming forward there are there's
closed-door congressional and Senate
briefings he's been part of them he's
admitted that before there's a new study
about UFOs because of this encounter
it's so much
evidence has so much power to it
compared to other ones the Christopher
Columbus great cool story somebody wrote
it down who news who knows if he even
wrote it down we have highly documented
cases this one has changed our culture
and that's what's so cool people are
talking about it differently
so here's this is a good story this is
true so sitting at home and usually when
people try and find me they get my wife
cell phone because it's the first one on
the cell phone ville and it's on my name
so I get I see this call from California
and I'm like you normally don't answer
them and it's her phone like whose call
my wife because that is me so I answer
it and this lady says hey is commander
forever there and I go who's calling she
goes well I'd like to talk to him at her
forever I go who's calling she says hi
I'm a 79 year old woman and I would just
like to tell him my story I go you're
talking to him and she goes I've never
in my life told anyone this
she goes my I grew up my dad was in the
Navy she goes I was he was stationed in
Rhode Island at first when she was a
child she said we were walking her and
her mom while walking on the beach and
they saw these weird lights so that kind
of got her into that Oh UFOs she goes
few years later they had moved to San
Francisco so I imagine Treasure Island
because at her age that would have been
you know right in the 50s her dad was
[ __ ] her dad is working as a Navy
liaison to the agency and he came home
one day and he had a telegram in his
hand and she goes for some reason he let
me read it she's told me this story and
I said well what did say she says it was
it basically said hey unidentified
objects going in and out of the water
and it had a latitude and longitude in
it and he looked at her she goes and I'm
a child I always remember that she says
he looked at me and said we get these
all the time and it's always in the same
area and I go of course I go well you
got the telegram she goes of course not
he had to take it back to work I said
you don't have to remember that
latitude/longitude she said no she goes
but you seem to be so credible and
believable she goes I wanted to tell
someone the story that I've never told
anyone in my life so that's what you're
starting to see is people that you know
very credible they're not you know
they're not they're not crazy they're
not making stuff up but they're coming
out and going hey I've had these
experience and I've got a lot of that
from for over the last two years where
people just find my email
and send me stuff saying hey this
happened to me I saw this and and
there's some things are explainable
because I got asked to tell this so
because we're kind of I have a sixth
sense of humor at times so like I said I
had all these koala
we used to fly they don't do it right
now because it's a little bit dangerous
but we used to fly night-vision goggles
low altitude in Hornets all right so
when you put on night-vision goggles
they amplify light
like a lot so you can see a campfire
like 50 miles away so we used to do it
the good spots were down in like al
central California there's a range that
there's some bombing ranges but people
go camping in the Superstition Mountains
which is a kind of north and west of
Imperial by I forget what it is the
springs it's real pretty in a desert
it'll come to me in a minute
so we even go out at night flying around
on goggles and you'd see a campfire and
you go up UFO time and then you get the
airplane going about 600 knots and then
you pull the power back to idle so you
can't hear it and you get zing in
towards the fire well you turn the
lights are all now because we're in
restricted area so we can do that and
there's lights on it that you can only
see if you're on night-vision goggles
so the other airplanes can see us but no
one else can see us you go zing and at
it and then right when you get to the
campfire you pull the airplane into the
vertical yes stroke the afterburners you
let them light off you count to three to
pull them off and then you just go away
instant UFO reporting I'm sitting out in
the desert it's all quiet and all of a
sudden there's a lure there's lights in
the sky and they go away and it's gone
like you would do that just to [ __ ] with
campers yes
yes I did not the only one who did it
but like I said we have a sixth sense of
humor yes so so some things are
explainable because I guarantee there
were phone calls made on some of the
stuff that we did and I guarantee you're
not the only one who's ever done that I
know I'm not yeah I'm not that creative
but it's just you know you think about
it you go because people go I saw this
or I saw that because I've got stuff
like that and I go yeah I used to create
stuff like that just not toes do you are
you Jeremy I'm sure you're aware of this
the footage from the the Mexican Air
Force yeah yeah very aware that what do
you think about that well again it's
it's IR footage which is really
interesting they actually got the
cameras for
runners right so you you can see in the
infrared so it's beyond the observable
you know I I myself have not detailed
looked at the footage however FLIR
experts and people that work with NSA
have looked at it for me and they these
are not lights in the distance
these are craft very similar to what
commander favor talks about without
plumes without heat signatures
you know non-traditional field
propulsion systems we don't have that
I thought they tried to assist it right
here it's just a mexican air force
footage yeah so they tried to say these
were lights on like an oil rig out in
the water that's been diba you say was a
fire mm to the comcast video of the year
was the mexican air force tracking like
six so literally right after our
incident I come and we come back and I
think we were getting ready to go to
fallon and i'm i had comcast and that
the homepage comes up and there's this
video and i go holy cow that looks like
what we chased and it was like six of
these things and they were tracking them
in the same area two right off the coast
Ensenada and it's not as rare there's
now admitted and increased frequency the
pentagon spokeswoman finally went
off-script i was tracking the scripts
for the last two years of what pentagon
spokespeople say about commander favors
experience someone went off script last
week in the new york times and she
admitted there's an increased frequency
of near misses because of these a AVS
anomalous aerospace vehicles so it's
pretty astounding we're getting all
these kind of revelatory moments in
these little seeds that these are not
ours we don't have this even Elan
doesn't have this I mean this is a
propulsion system unlike anything we
have it's amazing it's gravity propelled
now that gimbal footage when it said
that there's a fleet of them how far
away are those guys where you're seeing
you don't see the individual objects you
only see a singular spot well the pod is
you know when you get pretty narrow it'd
be like you know if I put three people
around you I can look at you and not see
the other people so that's what the pod
is doing but the radar is seeing
everything because it's a it has a nice
array dharna which is an active
electronically scanned array so instead
of like the radars we had which did the
mechanical you know doing this like
old-school
this thing is just a panel that sits in
the front of the airplane and through
beam sharing
beam's shaping it can move and it can
look all over so we used to have what
was called trackball scans so we would
be able to track a target why we're
still scanning this thing has scan law
but it scans while tracks so it it
literally if it sees you if the radar
sees you it has basically a weapons
quality solution then it can do that on
multiple targets is that's how it that's
the same way that the spy radar the
aegis system works on the cruisers they
can track multiple targets and have
weapons quality on all these different
targets while it's still scanning a
volume so in that image you're seeing
one individual object but there's other
objects yes the radar is seeing the
object that the pod is looking at where
they're talking and when you hear the
video you hear the the pilot say dude
look at the sa page there's there's a
whole fleet of them so what they're
seeing is the the the pod is looking at
the main that's the bigger object at the
gimbal the thing that's rotating on the
screen and there's five smaller things
in front so this thing's just sitting
there and then they kind of he said they
turn around on this on the radar and
start going the other way while the pods
looking at this guy just kind of
rotating so like a mothership and
smaller aircraft could be something
along those lines is there video of
those smaller aircrafts are just the
venom of the one large the only thing
they have is that the targeting pod I
would highly doubt even if they had the
video that they're gonna release the
radar video because of classification
levels are you able to tell the story
you told me about what was underwater
with your your other buddy because is
that okay yeah yeah
so it remains you know people come out
of the woodwork when they figure out you
feni's because now they don't feel alone
so I was working I'd worked I still do
it but I was doing oil and gas at the
time on a contract and one of the guys
the story came out and he was a Navy
helicopter pilot and he comes in he
comes in he goes Dee can I talk to you
man I go what am I guess I gotta talk to
you I said what do you wanna talk to me
about he says dude you know your UFO he
said yeah he goes I had a similar
experience I said what's that he said he
was flying ch-53 s which is a big lift
heavy lift that the Marine Corps uses
and the Navy uses it for certain things
and when they go off of for the East
Coast they do a lot of shooting off of
at the time it was off of Puerto Rico we
had Roosevelt roads that they ended up
close and
but he was flying out of there and you
know you got super clear Caribbean water
and they have these things called beak
um as they fly around and when they're
all done because they'll fly towards the
ships and the ship can sorry about that
they can track with the radar and then
they also do in a like the ships or
submarines shoot torpedoes there they're
called telemetry rounds so they have
they gather all the data on what the
torpedo or is doing underwater and then
they blow ballast and this thing will
come to the surface and float and then
they go pick them up and then they can
extract all the data out of them so they
do it for both so he said the first time
they're out and they're gonna pick up
his beak um and those things when
they're flying they're done a parachute
comes out and they gotta go they hook it
up the helo drops a swimmer in the water
he goes and hooks this whole thing up
then they hoist the whole thing up and
fly back and then they extract it in so
he says he's sitting in the front you
know in helicopters there's you know
c-53 you can actually see down by your
feet you know just like typical like you
got a Hawaiian ride so because you can
see when you're touching down so you got
really good visibility out of those
things and you can stick your head out
the window too because you're just gonna
hang it out he says he's going on there
and they're getting this thing hooked up
and as he's looking down you know cuz
they're I don't know what fifty feet
above the water he sees kind of this
dark mass coming up from the depths and
they starting to hoist the the diver up
and he's got they've gotten a beak um
and as they hoist it up he says and he's
looking at the single and what the hell
is that and then it just goes back down
underwater it's just like once they
pulled a kid in the beak um out of the
water this object descends back into the
deficit so he thinks well I was pretty
weird so he goes out he says not too
long later you know a few months later
he's out he's picking up a torpedo so he
says they got the they hooked the diver
up on the winch and they're lowering him
in and he's looking down he sees this
big massive because it's not a submarine
he's seen submarines before once you see
a submarine he can't confuse it with
something else this big object you know
kind of circular says it's coming up
from the depths and he starts screaming
to through the intercom system to tell
him to pull the diver up and the divers
like Fifi from the water so they've
reversed the winch and the divers
thinkin what the hell's going on and
he's getting pulled up and all of a
sudden he said the torpedo just got
sucked down underwater and the object
just descended back down into the depths
and they never occurred that that
torpedoes Jesus and this happened in the
late 90s late mid to late 90s thank you
I can pray get in touch with him and ask
him and he told me this story and I'm
like how do you report that you come in
and go well
where'd the torpedo go I just got sucked
down they just went down you know and
then you get to people that attribute it
as I something happened when it blew
ballasts and it just took on water and
sink and he's like it didn't sink he
goes it literally looked like it got
sucked down the only reason he didn't
they talked to him when they did the New
York Times stuff they talked to him but
it because the incident was from the 90s
they didn't want to they wanted
something you know newer mm-hmm so they
did not include it but I know they
talked to him about it now what was the
other footage that we were walking at
there was the first footage that Jamie
pulled up there wasn't a gimbal footage
go fast go fast what is that that's a it
actually looks more like a tic-tac but
it's they saw it going across the water
and they're they're just grabbing a lock
so they're seeing this with their eyes
and he gets the FLIR to lock out and
that's when you hear the kid go I got it
cuz he gets the AutoTrack and it's just
something screaming across the surface
of the water so and this is in the same
area
this is East Coast yeah this is the same
time frame as the gimbal video so the
idea that these are birds or the idea
that this is a radar glitch or somebody
said pilot error like on a clear blue
day commander flavor has nerves I mean
that kind of thing that people have said
on your show to you that you know this
these are explanations that make sense
who saw the I don't want to say that
West yes sure
Maina mint believes everything like
every single thing that's ever happened
has a rational explanation yeah it's so
that you know the probability that you
know all the radars went off at the
wrong time commander flavor you know had
nerves and all the other pilots up there
with him that you know this thing's shot
off like a like a can like a gun
instantly like that that was somehow
perfectly coordinated that's a
conspiracy that that's a fabrication
probably Occam's razor as the events
happen exactly like we're being told
yeah for us it was you know and I'll go
back to the beginning of the story of
you know the other pilot who was
brand-new yeah she had been in the
squadron for four months five months so
she's pretty junior she's still working
on her initial quality airplane and you
know so she gets the you know we get the
real world vector and it's like okay
real world vector cool I'm gonna get to
do something real exciting then you see
the
water and you think Oh something sinking
because it's kind of that shape of an
airplane you know that cross type so now
it's oh crap now it's search and rescue
we got to go down and see you know
because there's people you know and we
are sympathetic and to the tic-tac and
as soon as a tic-tac it's like I mean a
holy [ __ ] what is that you know and when
you get you know some people get very
emotional when you talk about it because
for me it was like yeah you know I you
know for her when you talk to her she
has a disdain for some of the leadership
that didn't tell us that these things
were out there you know they're here now
we're getting vectored because we were
the first time demand airplanes had been
airborne when one of these things showed
up that no one even gave us a brief that
hey we're seeing these objects out here
for the last two weeks they're just kind
of [ __ ] you might want to know they're
out there and they never told us
no one knew these things existed besides
the radar operators and the radar
operators didn't know what they were
they just knew they were seeing blips
you know so there's a lot of stuff that
you know that it flew around and it came
around me and it didn't do any of that
stuff it's the story that I gave you if
just relatively benign but it was you
know it's it's an interesting experience
so these incidents that they reported
were taking place before you saw your
that Tic Tac encounter yeah they they
were taking place over a period of how
many weeks two weeks we went out in the
beginning of the month for that's this
two-week ATS a period we pulled in for
Thanksgiving but other that we were out
till time December 21st is when we
pulled the ship back in besides pulling
in for three days at Thanksgiving so
yeah for the two weeks prior so this was
on the fourteenth and we went out at the
beginning of the month so about two
weeks they've been watching these things
come down go up come down go up but it
was always when we were not flying which
is really probably like the midnight
timeframe until early in the morning the
next you know till noon the next day and
then we just happen to go and if you
think about it you know I laugh it you
know if there was some little green man
flying around in that tic-tac he
probably got back to the mothership and
got yelled at for being seen like oh my
god you let him see you so so have you
communicated with anybody that has any
thoughts
why what these things are doing or the
the whether or not there's any
consistency to the size of them or
whether or not they think they're coming
out of a larger object or anything along
these lines no you know you can ask well
cuz I was asking you know what do you
think they were doing you know and I
said because you can look well they were
observing you know because they're
coming down and watching number two is
they were communicating because I think
you know in my heart I think there was
something under the water I don't you
know what it was doing there but because
of when you saw the X the cross looking
yep thing explained that again so the
disturbance may be in the shape of a
cross yeah like I described it as it's
about the size of a 737 so just think if
you submerge the 737 pointing it to the
east underwater by like you know 10 15
feet so as these waves are coming across
when they you know they hit that object
they're gonna break on top just like you
would with a submerge like a seamount so
and it's it's they're breaking and
that's where the tic-tac was that this
only reason we saw the tic-tac that's
what drew our eyes down there as we see
this whitewater when it's a perfectly
clear day with no Whitecaps and you go
oh what's that and then you see the
tic-tac and then we you know we do all
the chasing the tic-tac and we turn
we're right there
and we turn around and there's no white
water it's just blue as far as you can
see so at that point you go okay what
was it doing because there was obviously
something there that's not there now hmm
so that's where I say well it's it was
observing us it was could been
communicating with or whatever was there
you know and then someone else looked at
me and said you know I was talking to
Lou and he goes what about prepping the
battlefield I go okay you know so if you
go you know or these things from we
don't know you know are they from China
Russia someplace else I don't know but
it's a it's a capability that we do not
possess to my knowledge and if you asked
me in 2004 cuz there's a lot of guys go
out maybe it's some secret government
program I go alright well let's let's
let's be honest one if you have a
propulsion system that made it gave the
capabilities that we observed visually
that's a huge leap for mankind' period
so you would say yeah that was you know
think about its it's gonna be 15 years
next month
you know that we saw this I would like
to think that okay maybe let's just say
in 2004 it was something somebody had
this some government had this I don't
ours whatever
if you come to now you go 15 years later
you don't think that technology would
have emerged because it literally would
change everything we do I mean we're
happy about you know hybrid and electric
cars and all this other stuff but if
you've got something that works like
that air try would change our travel
forever
no visible percent system of propulsion
no what no plumes no it's just uh
yes we jokey and said that's a thing of
a 40-foot long tic-tac that can move at
will through the air at speeds well
beyond what we've ever witnessed I mean
even when you watch a rocket go off you
know one of Ilan's or one of the NASA
whatever you know you sit there and I
grew up during the Apollo ageism where
you just look at the thing go up up up
up up I've seen them shot out of
Vandenberg where you go you know I'd sit
in my house in central California and
you watch you go up and go I can watch
that thing for a while this is something
that just like poof a matter of seconds
is gone now our other pilots or other
people that have cited these things have
they also reported something larger
that's in the water near it no no not
the ones I've talked to I mean I think
you know you can get on History Channel
there's all this stuff on there about
people talking about stuff but you know
what here's the question is what do you
believe what you not believe and you
know my biggest frustration is the you
know our incident and even the folks on
the East Coast it is what it is to us
there's no reason to embellish there's
no reason to make stuff up but yet
there's still groups of people that are
making stuff up like someone came out on
ours was talking about and he's like I I
saw the whole the whole video is ten
minutes long and it was doing all this
it's [ __ ] what you see is that's
literally the entire video it's a minute
and a half long I think it's about a
minute and a half long what people
haven't seen that I saw I mean I've seen
the radar tapes because I had them as my
squadron you know I've heard you know
the men in black you know I just I'm
free you know maybe the okay I'll give
you the credit if they did but why
wouldn't they show
and talk to the guys who actually
witnessed it chased it and is one of the
senior guys in that group right it's
also possible that that men and black
stuff was something they used to do back
in the day and that that program was no
longer continued and you know from
Jeremy you would know this the older
sightings when they go back into the day
into historical sightings and I'm not
not Columbus but you know a 50s and 60s
did they have similar things that they
talked about or something moved in this
manner yeah it's absolutely incredible
and I want to dumb this down because
that's how I had to understand it when I
was talking with commander favor years
before I kept his secret years before
the New York Times blew it up I told him
it's probably gonna happen it wasn't by
me we were talking about it
this system that we have seen for over
70 years just documented by our military
this is so important this is a non
reactionary field propulsion system
everything we know is a reactionary
propulsion system you push something out
the back it goes forward this is not
like a mag system this is a
gravitational field propulsion system
and throughout history our military has
documented them and there has been
ridiculed now I'll tell you exactly why
1952 there was a huge flyover of
Washington DC jets were scrambled all
the papers covered it's very famous you
know case everybody can look up it's an
important case because at that time a
policy was started and that policy
started because it crashed our
communications that teletypes went down
the panic of the UFOs that were being
seen by people with fighter pilots
trying to capture and trying to engage
them and and it crashed the teletypes so
our government was like oh that's not
happening again because you know Russia
could use that as a scare tactic so this
policy of denial don't look here nothing
to see move on UFOs are fake
that's what Project Blue Book was tasked
to do specifically the guy who ran it
admitted that that it was tasked to
debunk this and demystify the UFO thing
that's J Allen Hynek correct right
I also yeah jr. Hynek um he was once
asked by a friend of mine do you have
the smoking gun I'll give you this
documents pretty amazed
it's an Air Force manual where they
explain what they know about UFOs at
that time in 1967 but here's the point
yes this has been going on since the
beginning of recorded human history
these propulsion systems that are
captured on footage you know that is
confirmed now by the net by the Pentagon
like commander flavors experience this
technology is not ours it's it was here
70 years ago you stole my 15 years ago
we didn't know we would see it now these
exact things at 20,000 miles an hour
going on 70 years ago documented
somebody has a non reactionary feel
propulsion system now are they aliens or
some subset of humans you know somebody
has them and they're fine
through our airspace with impunity and
pilots like commander favor who by the
way defended Los Angeles over not after
9/11 I mean this is a guy we put all of
our trust him he was defending Lausanne
just right after 9/11 so we got people
like him coming forward saying I saw
this and you got Internet warriors being
like it's a bird it's a glitch it's
Superman let's not concentrate on them
what about the Columbus thing did you
find that yeah it's just there's like
light 1492 light signature event that
they saw white in the distance because
it is the actual text no there's nothing
like Wikipedia stuff it's just one of
the oldest accounts I was trying to
throw out that this is something that do
you know of there's a very famous
painting that shows what appears to be
men in crafts flying through the sky in
the background of an ancient painting do
you know I'm talking about I do I
actually have a page one of the first
pages ever put on my website is like a
bunch of these because throughout
history there are these indications of
ships of crap but you know what the one
I'm talking about it's like and yes that
that's the shape of it it's also like a
plate turned on its side and then
there's a person inside of it yeah yeah
man it's it's flying through in that
same yeah that's it yeah
like look how it it's flying but you
know the thing is is it everybody can
say are the one above that's pretty cool
because that was a hidden thing I've
studied that one where it says
discovery fifteenth-century above the
her left shoulder there is an object and
if you really zoom in look at the dudes
staring up at it as a painter my wife is
a painter everything is intentional
which wears the ground of the ground
yeah right over there it's pretty cool
looking up so I think that's 15th
century it said so that the problem with
this Joe is it go to the original one
the one that we just looked at Jamie the
one right before that yeah so you get a
big picture yeah that is so strange like
here you got Christ being crucified and
then above him UFOs like is that
supposed to be aliens or is that
supposed to be angels like so what is
that supposed to be in these things that
they have it's severe it's real similar
to what we're talking about here that's
the argument of miracle of Fatima let's
say I mean again this is so speculative
we have a witness here of you know pilot
but when you see something like the
miracle of Fatima if you look at the
miracle of Fatima God that's that one
that was you know considered a real
miracle by the church and the three kids
we're getting messages I'll get this all
wrong but for like months that they're
going to be visited and to bring people
and bigger and bigger groups gathered to
where there was over a hundred thousand
people years of 1917 1917 so you know
dozens of thousands if not hundreds but
dozens for sure see an event a mass
sighting of something that happened
we're talking people that were religious
people that weren't religious you know
doctors that that's not a real image
there's a gym now one's doctored a
little bit so you could see what they're
all looking at something but that's not
real yeah that's the but that's the
crowd right the crowd is real is that
right so here's the thing people come
out something happened that was so
intense some people thought it was
religious that it was a visitation but
other people saw it as technological
like something descended you know look
into I'm just saying art pictures like
paintings we're talking about men you
can interpret them all day I can't hold
on to that I can't hold on to an
eyewitness with other eyewitnesses with
radar systems and with video we're in a
different era now we don't have to paint
it man we get to see it it's fascinating
man
it is fascinating but it's way more
faster
when someone like you talks about it
versus some [ __ ] random kook you know
that's that's what makes me incredibly
interested is the just your credibility
in the fact that this is not you know
I'm a history of seeing wacky [ __ ] that
other people don't see no just this once
and but it's the on video and that
there's other ones as well this it's
really strange that I've seen people try
to explain it away and what I don't like
about when they explained it away or
attempt to explain it away is that
they're trying really hard they're not
going who knows what this [ __ ] thing
is they're not looking at it like
cleanly they're looking at it like a
quote-unquote skeptic I don't like the
idea of being a skeptic not that I don't
think you should be skeptical of certain
things I certainly think you should be
but there's a lot of people that brand
themselves as skeptics and I think it's
a lazy way to look at things I really do
because I think you're just looking for
the holes in things without looking at
it objectively if you wanted to be a
scientist if you wanted to be someone
who is a fan of science then you have to
look at it as a thing like look at this
information and let's study this without
any bias any preconceived notions I
don't think they're doing that they're
looking at it they're trying to find a
way where they can justify that it's
fake and they're they're just doing all
sorts of mental gymnastics to try to
make it fake that video that you show
where that thing slips off to the left
and takes off at incredible rates of
speed that alone should freak people the
[ __ ] out yeah well I think because
people confuse all the time like we took
the video no it was another crew that
took the video we we watched it for five
minutes with our eyeballs and there was
four of us and we all have the same
story we all saw the same stuff we all
came back and looked at each other and
scratched her head and said WTF you know
I mean serious what was that you know
and then what do you do you you move on
we never saw it again I imagine they
probably saw him on radar after that but
I think they're probably seeing them on
radar all the time they just don't bring
it to the attention of the general
public oh yeah because if you don't you
know for for a ship when they see
something and you know you know what is
that well you don't have any way to go
out there and look at it
like when you're talking about how they
were informing you that they were seeing
these things previous to your your
mission when you're doing this exercise
and they let you know that they're
seeing these things did you say hey how
frequent is this is this something that
happens all the time I didn't get in
that ours was more of the moment of you
know when he's telling us save for the
last two weeks we've been tracking these
things right and we don't know what they
are but you don't know whether or not it
was just those two weeks or maybe it was
a year ago there was other similar
situations or there's other situations
that have happened out there but yeah I
would say you know for this I I don't
even know one you got to take it serious
we have a tendency if we don't know what
it is if we just ignore it it'll go away
you know and I joke you know there was
an incident years
miss prentace pry not too far off the
same timeframe where I think it was like
constellation was doing her work ups
before she got decommissioned and an
Oscar class of Soviet Oscar class
submarine surfaced behind her mm-hmm
right
and then it's now it's like you know go
to battle stations world war three how
did this how did this foreign submarine
get in our area and spend monitoring our
workups that's a big deal right I said
but now we go out and we have these
things that are coming out will there's
nothing we can do about it we don't know
what they are we have confirmed sighting
by two aircrew four of us two planes
that said look this is not this is not
an airplane this is not a weather
balloon this is not a blip it has
performance well beyond you know in the
airplanes that we were flying at the
time were literally brand-new super
hornets right out of the Boeing factory
I mean these these these were brand new
first block two series that came out and
you go why wasn't something done you
know it's like we don't know what it is
I think it's good now you know the moves
that have happened over the last you
know two years since the original
article came out that you know they're
there now there's a new reporting for
the pilots the Navy's acknowledged hey
these things we don't know what they
were you know they're they're starting
to take it serious because you know I
know there are other events that are not
out recent events where people have been
called in to go have seen this thing so
the investigation process is still going
on you know we don't
we don't study the military doesn't stop
even if you take funding away we don't
stop you know we don't stop until we're
told to stop so you know what's what's
going on I you know you go well a tip
ended you know they spent four and a
half million dollars a year on it I
think it was four nests 22 million over
the five years see you go what are they
doing since then well I mean I'm pretty
sure there's still people looking at
this and there's still people that are
taking this serious I will tell you that
I won't get into specifics but there are
there are people inside the United
States government that are taking this
serious and I've been I've went down to
DC twice to talk to folks you know
behind closed doors to go because they
want to hear the story and I've got a
lot of you got to be joking yeah I mean
this this seriously happened and and I'm
like yeah it did happen and it is real
you know what are you doing about it so
what kind of people are you talking to
high-level government officials is what
I'll say and most of that is because
that conversation is between me and them
and I don't want people speculating but
you can say high-level government
officials I have talked to well that was
always the the speculation about like
what would someone do if they became
president well the first thing I would
do is I would tell everybody about the
UFOs I would ask immediately what's
going on and I always thought about I
said how many people actually know
what's going on and how much of the
information I mean it's not like if
they're dealing with something like this
like your experience it seems like what
you described is what is known so it's
this anomalous event with this thing
defies our current understanding of
technology and then it's gone yes and so
what do you have you don't have anything
else other than that like what other
information does anybody have well I
would say I would say this because I've
talked to Bob we did a table czar yeah
we did an event together and I'll leave
it to everyone to if he it's up to you
to believe Bob I'll say this
Bob's a normal guy Bob's not crazy he's
not crazy at all not at all that was the
weirdest thing about talking to him but
when you when you look at it and go
because I had asked Bob I said what he
describes in the technology when he
talks about his
his story I said well do you honestly
think we could you know reverse engineer
it I said how long do you think it would
take us and his response to me was
another hundred years he goes Dave it
was so far beyond he goes the stuff that
he says he worked on he's like you know
there was on your podcast cuz I watched
it you know hey there was no wires and
because I had asked him when he said you
first described the ship that he got to
see he said I used to say you know they
built it and then it was like wax and
you'd heat it up he goes now I would say
it was built with 3d printing because
now a 3d printing we didn't know things
literally from the ground up and it's
basically built as one not panels no
rivets it's just made right and so when
you talk about that and you go well it's
still another 100 years so you go well
what if you had the technology we still
if if what Bob says is correct we still
don't understand it and how fast would
it take us to understand that
I mean if it's if it's driven by
something that we don't even have on
earth which is when he talks about that
element we can't create it you know we
can create it for a microsecond and then
it you know it decays and we call them
at 115 yeah so you know I think we're
we're still a long ways off you know
I'll argue with the people that go you
know are we really alone I was telling
Jeremy we used to go out on on goggles
you know out in the middle Pacific
there's no light poles night-vision
goggles so we can see well you go out at
night and he'd be on like a tanker
hopper so I'm just hanging out not doing
anything driving around in circles with
the autopilot on you just turn all the
lights down in the cockpit so you have
no night light pollution and you just
look roll your head back and look up
there's billions and billions and
billions of stars out there and you know
I always look up cuz I'm like you know
are we alone and I go I look up and go
well if we're the only ones around and
that's and I'm looking everything I'm
looking at some it's a pretty sad place
it's a pretty lonely universe I asked my
astrophysics prof that once I said you
believe in extraterrestrial life and
she's like of course not and I said well
there's billions and billions of planets
you think we're it I mean just the
probability of it is you'd go other Spri
something else out there and I'm not
crazy I'm just opening up the
possibility that we are not the only
planet that has life on it I think
people don't like to seems
silly they don't like to be foolish and
I think when people start talking about
anything that's not proven or anything
that's connected to a bunch of loony
people that are making up stories which
UFOs certainly are yes UFOs are
connected to so many people that have
made up so many stories was that
gentleman's name from what you would
know that guy was from another country
Billy something or another Billy - yeah
seems a hundred percent full of [ __ ]
yeah yeah he's proven to have done tons
of hoaxes with this but here's the deal
sometimes I think people have a real
experience and they're always like
chasing that dragon and they get UFO
disease and the brain goes [ __ ]
berserk right I know that there are
people that have had profound
experiences and then they can't ever
replicate them so then they just start
going crazy and I don't blame them for
it but you got some of that command of
flavor when he saw that AAV anomalous
aerospace vehicle his reaction was I
want to fly it that's a pretty cool
reaction I'd like to fly it yeah imagine
flying that thing well that's what I
told my buddy is my XO at the time Dell
got back after all this happened he
looks I mean we're just standing right
here when he goes hey dude I go it he
goes what do you think it is I go I have
no idea but it was pretty freakin
impressive and I'd like to fly it Corps
and he goes yeah I go I mean it was it
was you know it's just like any putt you
always want to follow coolest thing
worse yeah of course you race car driver
you want to drive the fastest car that's
it now you look at and go well that's
some we don't have yeah this idea that
you know maybe we're not alone that some
of these other stars have planets that
or maybe technologically advanced so the
next thing people say and you know new
eras are going to say well they're not
coming here because the distance is so
vast hold the [ __ ] up from the very
beginning when Bob Lazar came for and
talked about field propulsion gravity
propulsion distance becomes completely
irrelevant so if we believe the and the
radars are right and commander framers
saw this thing moving like a ping-pong
ball in glass water it's gravity
propelled that's why you can make those
maneuvers without exploding okay then
distance becomes completely irrelevant
for travel
you're literally warping time and space
you're falling into place
well it's like the idea of showing
someone a video on your phone long
before video was ever invented
people like what are you talking about
like before photography was invented
which is shockingly recent right you
ought to draw pictures of things you saw
just like those people that drew or
painted that those images of those men
and whatever those things were with
Christ in the background the idea that
we could understand what some insanely
impressive technology from a planet that
is nowhere near us could could manifest
that's great it's nuts
yes but Bob Lazar talks a lot about this
remember he's a young guy right in 1989
he gets shown something and all of a
sudden he's trying to interpret it
through 1989 technology so he said it
looks like it was injection molded
because that's what he had and then Ron
I said him this thing about
nanotechnology and you know working
towards an atomic printer he's like dude
that makes a lot more sense so he has to
view it through where he saw it in 1989
however I will say this it is my
knowledge that we understand exactly how
these crafts work our one limiting
factor is our material science we can't
replicate not the fuel source itself is
another when you say we know exactly how
they work yeah it doesn't break our laws
of physics this concept of amplification
of gravity this concept of gravity
propulsion we understand how things can
move from point A to point B almost
instantaneously our physics doesn't
disallow it but our material science and
the fuel to create that machine that we
we have machines from other places so we
I mean well Bob Lazar whether you
believe him or not that there was a
program I have other witnesses that I
will be bringing forward about s4 where
he worked
we have cred of other witnesses that
worked with along the people that
corroborate Bob's account in that they
saw him get on and off the red and
whites the Janet flights that come on
mm-hmm somebody that went to Papoose
Lake and was stopped by non-military
guards at that time people that were
aware of sight four and et exploitation
projects one is an sr-71 pilot that I've
been talking with for a couple years so
these people are coming for now which
and it's like I'm sick and tired of
doing it these little nitpicky things
about
Bob okay there was a program there was a
back engineering program they've
admitted there are materials so this is
like the meta materials you heard about
in the New York Times all that we have
materials associated with UFOs that are
interesting what is that what are you
talking about so this was something that
was launched in the first New York Times
article I believe in December of 2017
that there is studies being done right
now on materials associated with UFOs
right so actual metals that have come
off of you could say crashes or who is
that that explained that there was
something that they were with Eric
Weinstein that was explaining that there
was someone who reportedly has something
along those shocks ballet has 17 samples
17 samples how does one night at 17 Sam
well he's jock [ __ ] ballet right so
he is the guy first ever for the United
States military created a computer
program for you know for the study of
UFOs for Project Blue Books he's an old
school guy they modeled him after in the
Close Encounters movie it's modeled
after Jacques Vallee the French guy so
he's kind of like been involved with
this he's had more access to government
databases than any of us he went around
collected samples from known you know
crashes or like when things will come
off and what's the conclusion well
they're studying him right now there was
just something on Fox about they're
studying some of these materials and
what they will find because I actually
the ones they're talking about I
actually took to New Mexico and had five
scientists study it about five years ago
I got my hands on it got to study it the
the famous parts they're talking about
now it's layered and the way it's
layered is what they're trying to see if
its anomalous elementally or the way
that they're the elements are bound
together and also the atomic level of
layering is what's interesting we'll
find out if we explain what you're
talking about what is this thing that
you saw okay well there is there are a
lot of different samples but when you
get a sample of something and you can
come bigger these samples the ones that
that I looked at they ranged from about
this size they were you know they range
from the size orange-y a size of an
orange to the size of a quarter these
are materials right the materials from a
crash so that's the alleged layer
there's a known crack
this is in the public domain rather than
you know government control so what we
were what I was looking at or having the
scientists look at is isotopically and
elementally what are the elements that
are in this are they engineered and
what's the conclusion well I I'm not I'm
gonna leave it to the people that are
doing it now who have much better
machines than I had a million cliffnotes
yeah they from what I understand there's
atomic layering there there are levels
of like we do with graphene we lay down
these layers that are basically oriented
at a certain degree that's how you get a
superconductor or something like that if
you take a piece of graphene and you and
it's highly machined so it's not doesn't
deviate from that atomic layering you
can push it right through ice thick hot
knife through butter so the weirdest
feeling in the world because you just
take this piece of what feels like
graphene and it goes right through
butter because it's a superconductor and
the heat from your hand melts the ice so
that that is a meta material it doesn't
occur naturally humans created it and it
has special properties because of the
way it's atomically layered so if these
materials are from somewhere else then
they're we suspect that they're going to
be highly machined that they're going to
be created for special use so my whole
point is our material science has not
caught up with the physics that we
understand for these field propulsion
systems I'm just telling you believe me
or not but you'll hear more about it
that that our material science in 1989
and today is our limiting factor and as
our material science gets better as
humans we know how these things work now
the fuel source that's a whole nother
conversation but as far as creating
these machines that's what we're trying
to do that's why there is secrecy we're
trying to exploit the technology because
whoever exploits it first wins it's a
game changer we don't want Russia to do
it we don't want China to do it if we
had a non reactionary propulsion system
the world would look different
instantaneously what what is your
perspective after the incident versus
before the incident like how much did it
change the way you view the world and
our place in the world for me I mean I
always I never believed that we were
alone
me I just look up and go there's way too
many stars up there for us to be my own
place after it you know it makes it a
little more clear to go you know one my
questions are where to come from that's
that's the biggest one of where'd it
come from
what was it doing you know and then I've
asked why me
I mean why why did I happen to be
because you can say wrong place wrong
time right right place to see or right
place right time for me it was I think
there's more out there and if I could
get word out to anyone it's like you
know especially the debunkers of one
quit trying to debunk it because it is
what it is it wasn't a there wasn't a
system glitch this I mean this was a
real incident that happened and number
two is let's open our aperture a little
bit and start thinking outside of the
box you know if you go you know you look
at it go ahead it's it's non reactive
propulsion well it's because when we
came up with propulsion we D we you know
the people long before us came up with a
reactionary propulsion system and that
became our standard had we done
something different or we developed non
reaction we might look at something like
a gasoline engine go holy cow how's that
thing work right we wouldn't have that
idea so you know I think there's you
know if you look at it and go people
thought Einstein was kind of nuts and
we're still proving his theories today
and what we're learning is that he was
right and he was right there was a time
when the earth was flat except for some
people in California the earth isn't
flat around its people there's not an
ice wall so so when you look at that and
you go you know a lot of the stuff that
we thought was true isn't true it's
totally been changed so for me I just
say I think let's get outside of the box
and go if we can develop a technology
that would and I don't look at it from a
military standpoint because it would be
a game-changer from military standpoint
technology like that would be a
game-changer for mankind completely I
mean it would literally everything that
we do you know and we don't know exactly
you know you could you know do you want
that system in a car you know people
have trouble driving in two dimensions
let alone three right you know they you
know it's kind of like your joke last
night
the vaping thing let alone drive in a
car that goes up down works in three
dimensions or that was what they
originally wanted helicopters to be they
wanted to be flying cars yeah if you get
out on the road you see how people drive
yeah and I always laugh because people
think well we're three-dimensional like
we know that this table is not the floor
but it really humans are two-dimensional
people and you learn that especially
when we would fight if you can really
work in the third dimension which is up
and you go well we are three dimension
like I know if you look at like a tall
building is you know 1700 feet high the
big ones and you go no you know for an
f-18 to do a split us which is go from
up here and just do a vertical 180
degree turn so you're going this way and
you go down here it's like 2500 feet
hmm and that's tight that's a tight turn
for a jet you know unless you're running
like vectored thrust stuff but there's
everything has a cost so if you do some
big high akka you bleed off energy
there's a cost associated that that to a
pilot that's three dimensions to most
people on earth you go no I'm you know I
look at a hill and god I want to walk up
that thing Rio and in an airplane it's
it's a totally different thing so if we
just open up that expanse you know for
what we're trying to do for technology
and go is there another way because we
still build we still build suckers and
blowers which is a jet engine
we just refined the internals the
turbines to get them to be more
efficient where I go I don't you just
put your efforts at someplace else like
I was talking to there's a whole realm
of physics that really doesn't get
explained and it's I was talking to
Steve Justus about it it's more into the
magnetics type side that we don't we
don't spend a lot of time on and I know
he said when he was working at skunk
works he did it's not a good call I read
internal research and development money
that he would fund to try and look at
some of these other technologies for
propulsion and you know he's now since
retired but really impressive to talk to
him at the level that you can which is
you know for us would be an unclassified
level but you know the stuff that goes
on behind closed doors there's reasons
for it you know because if a technology
like that got out where someone could
rapidly reproduce it after all you've
done you know or they got it first do
you think of the atomic bomb you know
Germans almost had it
Russians were working on it we got it
first changed the world
literally changed the world when we
detonated the first one and you go I'm
not gonna get into the politics behind
it but now we had it and now it was the
race everyone else because they had to
get on equal part because it's a
destabilizing thing and novice side if
you develop a technology like this and
you keep it to yourself you've got
something that no one else has and it's
a huge leap I mean it's a quantum leap
do you do you share it because it's a
mankind thing or do you keep it for
yourself you know and that's right now
it's not for me to decide I'm just Dave
well it's fascinating that some other
method of propulsion could have been
established in some other place and that
we're experiencing or that you've
experienced it and some other folks have
experienced it in action and I just
think for us as people as human beings
in 2019 it's really easy to think that
what we have now is so amazing and that
what we have now is the pinnacle of
discovery and then what we have now is
you know with our electricity and with
our LED screens and that we are
experiencing like the height of
Technology when if you're some creature
from some other planet that has got easy
access to element 115 and some gravity
propulsion system you're looking at us
like we're digging holes in the side of
a mountain to protect ourself in the
rain we're a cave people yes yeah what
we do that here on earth yeah I mean you
look at like a first world you know like
a United store you know these are the
[ __ ] of developed nations I need to go
to Sammy's other and go you know people
are still getting their water out of a
hole in the ground with a bucket right
or people in the rainforests are living
these indigenous lifestyles yeah so you
know take them something take them one
of these flat screens down in one of
these tribes that no one's ever seen and
go hey yeah and start showing them
pictures of themself that you're
shooting real-time or video that's
feeding directly into it they'll freak
out don't think I would you capture my
soul right so it's it's where we add
more are we gonna do and what can we do
did it change the way you look
life I mean even though you knew that or
you had this feeling that we were not
alone just from looking at the Stars and
but when you actually see the thing like
how I mean I would imagine that that has
got to really shift your perspective
well if it shifted my perspective but it
was more of a it's a validation a
confirmation ago you go yeah you know
I've always like yeah there's a lot of
stars and then you see something like
this and go well maybe we're not because
that that pushes you to the next point
to go you know you know one lands in my
front yard then I'll be 100% sure that
we are not alone because it's sitting in
my front yard but I mean I got within a
half mile of this thing which is people
go I have miles pretty far away I got
not when you're flying an airplane
half-mile is like really tight when they
bring you in to have these conversations
with high-level government officials how
long these conversations so I went to
the I've been down I've talked to three
different groups of people this is post
The Times article so the New York time
article comes out in 2017 yes and then
our compliment the other pilot that was
involved had been to DC multiple times
this is how our kinda I got in touch
with Lou she had called me and said hey
I need to talk to you so I called her
and I said what's going on she says hey
have you been there's anyone called you
about the tic-tac and I said no she goes
you know I'm gonna the Pentagon like a
half dozen times and they'll take me in
and anywhere from Starbucks to you know
inside of a vault and she goes and
they'll talk to me about the story and
they'll show me a picture something goes
to look like this and then she gets
pretty frustrating goes it we called the
tic-tac because it looked like a tic-tac
what part don't you get I mean go get up
thing at Tic Tacs and look at when
they're saying did it look like this
they showing her something laughs that
they have no not pictures that they have
but like a video from someone else like
they'd show the gimble video like this
okay and it was no so and that's when I
told her I said well just just tell this
guy that you're talking to just give my
name and number I go I'll talk to him
it's not a big deal to me you know and
that started so when we I got asked you
know multiple times to go down and talk
to two people one of them was supposed
to be 20 minutes and these you know
these are important people get in 20
minutes as some of these folks time is
that's a huge deal so we went in
thinking okay we're gonna do the thing
20 minutes and then we're in and and an
hour and a half later we came out I mean
that's the interest of you know and
there were some Pino you get the group
you know the folks that come in and out
but there's a few that just sat there
and were enamored by what we were saying
like you're you joke and we're like no
this is this is all real I mean these
are these are pre senior officials that
are taking the time out of their day to
take this serious to go you know maybe
we do need to put a little emphasis on
this I mean literally if some can just
show up at will and do whatever it wants
and I'd probably at least pay attention
yeah pay attention but what could be
done I mean what could they do if you
put yourself in a position of one of
these high-level government officials
what do you do just spend more money on
looking at them now if you look at money
though I mean I know when the article
came out and they talked about the a tip
program that Harry Reid got funded 22
million dollars over five years yeah
point four million dollars a year and
you go and one's freaking out oh it's 22
million I know I wasn't 22 million
dollars a year
it was 4.4 million that's not even in
the rounding error for the United States
we just gotta prove what it was seven
hundred and fifty billion dollars for a
defense budget seven hundred and fifty
billion if it took a hundred million out
of that it's not even gonna put a dent
and I go why can't you know if you're if
you're only spending four or four point
four million dollars a year and you can
actually get some good work done because
you don't need a huge team because you
figure if you look and I think I think
what's the number like ten fifteen
percent of all these UFOs like you would
you look at Project Blue Book really
remained unexplained and you go okay so
you can weed out you know you can read
out me flying over someone in a campfire
in like my afterburners so you know that
was Dave being Dave so you can weed that
stuff out now you go now I'm really kind
of concentrating the funds the most
important thing and I talked to the
folks one that we were talking we talked
about funding and I said let me leave
you with this and I had got some pretty
good stuff I was talking to Chris Mellon
who's a former undersecretary and
understands how the government works so
is where he gave me some really good
feedback and I said I talked to I said
look I'm all for you guys funding a
program but what you need to do is find
a program that there's going to be
oversight over when I say oversight I
mean because what happens is you go
here's money but we're going to
distribute in the government
so we're gonna distribute it to these
three different agencies across the
United States government you know I
don't just call them agency a B and C so
you give it to them
you know and I'll go back to like the
9/11 stuff where we've really had the
answer but all the agencies weren't
talking to each other to put all the
pieces together and that's my fear that
you go hey we're gonna take a hundred
million dollars of taxpayer money we're
going to fund a program to actually
seriously investigate this stuff and
look at the technology but there are
three different entities working on
their own and not talking to each other
so there's got to be a joint
collaborations we go we're gonna do it
but you know Joe's going to be in charge
and you guys are all gonna play nice in
the sandbox together because we want to
get our money's worth because people
pull raise the the fraud waste and abuse
flag that we're wasting money on
something stupid now the gimble video
shows a different kind of thing
yes how many different kinds of things
are you aware of well those are ours too
if you look at the go-fast it kind of
looks like a tic tac so you could say
those two are the same
yeah I think there's other stuff out
there you know and sometimes it's not
that the you got to look at where do you
obtain the video it's just like
intelligence you know and I'll use
because I had no you got that picture of
Pablo out there you know and there was
the guy Tom Cruise made the movie about
him what's his name Louisiana due to his
flying the drugs for Pablo in and out
Barry seal Barry seal you know hey it
was all great until Reagan posted that
picture that they had the cameras inside
the cargo plane and then Pablo puts it
there the only place that picture came
from is Barry seals airplane you know
and then now Barry seals a dead man so
you got to watch when you release
because you go hey we got this video but
it was taken someplace we probably
weren't supposed to be or how did they
get that video right like I look the
video of the tic-tac video that thing
first came out is kind of funny the guy
that was in my backseat had sent me an
email and this is about probably 2008 so
I was retired and he sent me this video
guys say skipper's look familiar
and it was on strange land calm but not
suitable for work just say that but I
look and then next thing you know it's
on YouTube so when I would tell this
story to my friends I would go I'd send
them a link to the YouTube video and
this is
years before the New York Times article
and then when they did the unofficial
official report the you the video was
taken down off of YouTube and you know
it kind of puzzled me like why'd you
take the video down and I told the guys
when they did the unofficial official
products that way you really need to
look as how did this thing come off of a
classified Drive system on an aircraft
carrier and end up on strange land calm
in YouTube because at the time the
videos were classified secret and that's
not because it was a UFO it's the the 80
Flair video what they did not want that
released so you'd see it on CNN they
blocked out all the performance stuff
what the airplane was actually doing in
this case you know the one you see it's
250 knots of the autopilot on so it's
not that big of a deal but you know
Jeremy how many different types of
vehicles are you aware of that have been
reported credible reports for decades
hundreds of different shapes even Lazar
himself said he saw you know nine
different styles all working off the
same propulsion system the tic-tock
shape you know vehicle that that goes
back in history some people say cigar
shaped you know big ships small ships we
you know they're all different kinds I
think it's important to state though
there are other funded government-funded
UFO programs it's a misnomer actually
that a tip was the recipient of the 22
million dollars it was actually harry
reid created a program called AUSA
awesome was the sole beneficiary of that
22 million new york times got it wrong
and then what happened is a tip was a
different funded program to study
military encounters with UFOs aw snap
was created because of skinwalker ranch
a government program to study UFOs and
associated phenomenon a tip and awe sup
communicated and shared information but
they were independently funded so the 22
million dollars was for OSAP and then a
tip had its own sources and then they
did collaborate to UFO programs there
are more that I think we're gonna learn
about so the different shapes that bob
lazar saw there was nine different
shapes that he saw yes there's only one
up close yeah and none of them were like
to tic-tac not specifically however
that's not an uncommon if you go back in
history of like military sightings of
craft going
over 20,000 miles an hour the tick-tock
is a shape they have triangles they have
ones that look like rectangles the thing
that is common with all of them is the
non reactionary propulsion system I
think even command a favor said the
thing noticed him was words he first
said to me and and kind of went towards
him with its nose but it could move in
any direction right I mean it could just
move that will however it was when we
first thought it was just basically it
never turned it was just going left
right you know kind of doing this she
probably doesn't matter and then it
became aware because it turned and it
actually mirrored what I was doing when
I was coming down it came up and you
know so it was obviously knew we were
there and I don't know if it was picking
up you know energy coming off the
airplane or what you know I do know that
when they tried to lock it it actively
you know it jammed a radar made it
pretty much useless and you know Chad
was pretty good about kicking it over
and grabbing that video so it's pretty
wild it's a big deal to actively jab a
radar virus you know yeah it's um you
know whenever someone tells you an
awesome story it's great to hear but god
I wish I saw it myself you know yes but
you got thing that's yeah you're like
you're telling me and I'm like wow I'm
listening I'm trying to imagine I'm
putting it in my head I'm I'm I'm
visualizing it but damn I wish I could
see it yeah I said this to a guy where
he's he's pretty proud I don't say who
it was or what his position was he's
pretty prominent in the UFO community
I'm not really a UFO guy and he starts
quoting like Jeremy can't quote event so
this was this dis event that event that
of it and it keeps looking he goes what
do you know about this event I go nope
and he goes what about this event I go
nope he gets like three of them and I
look at him and he goes well you're not
UFO guy I go no but I chase what have
you he goes no I go I'm an expert you're
the kind of school he kind of got
deflated a little bit he because he
looked at me like you suck well it's
like people that are into baseball stats
but they've never played yeah yeah you
know you gotta get got your hands dirty
get out in the few I'm with you Joe like
I wish I had seen you I've been so
curious about the propulsion system
since lazar and I wish I could see
something too oh my god yeah I would
give so much I'd almost think about
for president just to win just so I
could get in and find out about you
everybody's track and then go I quit
[ __ ] everybody Clinton tried he tried
to eat yo big time that was his that he
came in he said first thing he webster
hubbell he said i want to know two
things who killed JFK and i want to know
all about UFOs and they were he was
denied access and he later said it's not
the first time I've been lied to her
denied information after asking for it
Bill Clinton said that
additionally Jimmy Carter he said before
he was president I'm gonna find out well
Jimmy Carter supposedly saw you know he
did he said I'm gonna find out I'm gonna
tell you never talked about it again
afterwards after he became president
wonder what his briefing looked like you
know and then so many presidents have
tried because they're like us man
they're curious mm-hmm however this
information from my understanding which
is an informed understanding is so
compartmentalized you know that makes
sense
listen is anything else just one thing I
want to make sure to brief you on storm
because I still blame you for it a
little bit no idea can I just give you a
quick break now okay so check this out
I made a movie Bob Lazar Air Force One
and flying saucers Joe blows it up I go
on a show with Bob Lazar which was
awesome thanks for letting Bob tell
everybody what happened and then the
world lit on fire
now from a sociological pop-culture
standpoint what happened on that day is
huge and I don't want it to be missed on
anybody so a kid watches your podcast
watches the movie puts up this Facebook
page Stormare 51 oh my god that's a big
problem right so I ended up talking to
the kid and all this and helping trying
to help him navigate kid went left he
should have gone straight anyway vent
went down Rachel Nevada where area 51 is
where the access points go up we all
went out there right but really Rachel
nobody wanted people to come it's a town
of fifty two people one business the the
residence I live in Pioneer Tom Coburn
it's tiny you don't want your whole town
taken over by potentially dangerous
millions of people that are signing up
for this on on Facebook right so it's
this huge phenomenon that happened
because of going on what happened so
here's what actually happened because
the media has completely lied to you
they said 150 people showed yeah it's a
total fabrication
the footage to prove it we had an event
in we I participated in an event in
heiko Nevada which is safely 50 miles
away from you know Rachel where they
didn't want us and on the fly 3,000 plus
it's me it's a huge win three thousand
plus people even though they were scared
to come because they were told to be
scared to come out there that it's gonna
be a riot okay and they peacefully
assembled and enjoyed this thing I had
but what what happened there was nothing
they just got together 3,000 people yeah
but everybody came with the idea that
they're curious about this it engaged a
whole new audience of people we had Dave
Foley talked we had Paul Oakenfold some
famous people talked the phone setup
yeah we had a I set it up I brought in
speakers right I brought in speak Dave
did you avoid this yeah I'm you know I'm
a military guy not forming a government
that's about the stones go that's like
jumped the White House fence I'm like
are you black that's the dumbest idea on
the planet yeah I didn't understand the
benefit of getting all those people
together no no people were going and so
my point was well let's at least bring
people who can talk about it and and
have a civilized fun time and see what
people want to do so my point is it's
amazing anybody came out to begin with
and nobody went crazy so what is the 150
people that were reported where they may
be at the gate itself to go so that's
probably what it happened and someone
like you didn't come along and organize
something else yeah I didn't organize it
but I definitely advocated for safety
and and it worked and and it was a
success so they just got together and
talked 3,000 people got together and
talked well it was spread out all
throughout like people didn't Rachel the
community didn't want people there was
an event there though and the in heiko
where I was was the event with the stage
and the fun stuff we all did George
Knapp was was there as well how did you
promote this well they did the event
they promote it because people are
already coming didn't promote it on
social media sure I said if you're gonna
go somewhere that's where I'm gonna be
and it's gonna be safe and sane my point
is this you have so many people that are
curious now and don't underestimate what
happened on when someone watched your
podcast and that happened boom you've
got all these new people who are
interested in it and I think that's
important because this UFO phenomenon is
real you've got
fighter pilots that engage them it
represents a non reactionary propulsion
system and that's a physics that would
change the world
so the more people that come together
and say we're interested the louder the
voice we got I think it's cool when I
had some alien Budweiser great well I
don't know if there's really any benefit
to people physically getting together
but I do think that there's a lot of
benefit I'm glad you had a good time but
I just think there's a lot of benefit to
this discussion and and I really think
there's a lot of benefit to hearing the
stories from people like you because
that's the only thing that matters to me
when it's like I need to know the person
who's telling me the story isn't full of
[ __ ] so when I get it from someone like
you
I really really appreciate it so um
that's it thanks for being here thanks
for telling your story thanks for having
thanks for being you thank you Jeremy
for setting us up and thanks for your
documentary on bob lazar which really
like [ __ ] turned me around
that was the one all right that's it bye
everybody
[Music]